this is the new iPad pro it has a
brilliant twelve point nine inch display
weighs a pound and a half and can be
used with an optional keyboard and
stylus but none of those details
outshine this simple fact this thing is
huge this may be hard to convey in a
video but get your hands on a pro and
its size is almost overwhelming the pros
larger display means you can enjoy even
bigger videos and draw and markup on
bigger pages
it changes the idea of an iPad from
being a very sophisticated viewing
device to becoming a much larger digital
canvas onto which you can express the
full warp and weft of your imagination
at least that seems to be the eyebrows
intentional thing is I don't know about
you but I've always used my standard
size iPad for a handful of things
watching movies reading stuff online and
maybe playing a game or two yes in a
pinch I've used it to write stuff but
when I really need to get down to
business I still go to my exceedingly
well-designed MacBook Air in an attempt
to bridge that gap the pro can be
equipped with Apple's smart keyboard
cover as well as a stylus called the
Apple pencil
both are the best keyboard cover and
stylus I've encountered but that
opinions only useful to you if you like
keyboard covers in Scylla
I don't i still like a standard keyboard
and that's for the stylus well I can't
draw and I don't really see that
changing anytime soon and that's why I'm
not jumping up and down about the iPad
pro but I have a hunch I don't think I'm
the intended customer for the iPad pro
maybe my colleague Steffes and she's a
graphic designer
but the customer who's really in Apple
sites I think is a chief technology
officer he or she may see it in concert
with some hardcore business apps as an
on-site portable dashboard or traveling
presentation device and then he or she
is going to go out and buy iPad pros by
the hundreds having successfully
conquered the consumer market Apple
wants a piece of the enterprise now too
they named it the iPad pro for a reason